if you live near Nellis Air Force Base  you're used to that noise  and it's coming back red flag exercises  start up again tomorrow up at Nellis  they're going to last several weeks  Crews stationed at Nellis and the Nevada  test and training range are going to be  flying through the day and the night red  flag training runs to July 29th yes  we're used to the sounds if you love the  Northeast part of the valley you know  what the afterburners are like and what  the Jets are like it's just kind of par  for the course don't need to see them up  in the air though you know oh all over  the valley yeah I'm down by Henderson  Executive Airport where this sounds more  expensive those private jobs  no yes they fly with their pinkies out  yeah